you
thus the r-class ocean Langan the
a-class hasn't been the same since the
introduction of the new generation but
now our car reviewers sasha is looking
forward to the a45 AMG it has an output
of 265 kilowatts 450 newton meters of
torque first question is getting to
grips with that power the design of the
new a-class took everyone by surprise
the message was youth in terms of the
model itself and the target group the
same applies with the a45 AMG as the
entry-level model from Mercedes Benzes
performance on its intended to appeal to
younger drivers and it certainly has
some convincing arguments
the Eiffel of the a45 AMG accelerates to
100 kilometres an hour in a brutal 4.6
seconds that sports car standard but
bear in mind that we have the same
software for the direct shift gearbox as
in the SLS AMG the a 45 s engine is over
4 liters smaller than the SLS AMG so
it's all the more surprising to see the
amount of power it can deliver guns cars
highlight reminds the top highlight for
developer markovits Lizzy engine AMG
fitted a two liter four cylinder engine
with a twin-scroll turbo and created the
most powerful four-cylinder in the world
it has two hundred and sixty five
kilowatts 364 pounds let's discover you
Kleist I noticed is pierced the
engineers also paid attention to
efficiency and the environment the
engine already meets the eu6 emissions
norm for years ahead of time and has a
official consumption of just 6.9 litres
of premium unleaded for 100 kilometres
but that's only if driving
conservatively this is the sound you get
when you really step on it
depending on the drivers skills and the
conditions you can switch the ESP to
sport handling mode or just turn it off
but under everyday conditions the cars
dynamism is no less impressive marvel at
the acceleration from a standing start
top speed electronically camp is 250 kph
and to ensure that the driver feels the
power pumping through the car top
caliber tuner team at AMG have a trick
or two up their sleeves
funeral t 450 newton meters of torque
are some package to deliver to the road
points out sasha AMG has installed
permanent four-wheel drive that means
you can step on the gas again at the
apex of a bend without having to worry
about flying out of controls the
Corbett's of heat and the AMG edition is
also proud of its looks it's contouring
is bold and sinewy its veins running
from the front down the sides 18-inch
alloy wheels carbon fiber mirror
housings and AMG performance brakes all
subtle indications that you're behind
the wheel of a super sports car chomping
at the bit sizeable air inlets and the
uncharacteristically long engine hood
make the new generation a real
headturner
and behind the hatch we find ample space
in the back feel I still has the money
performance and interior space do not
have to be mutually exclusive so Sasha
here we have 341 liters of cargo space
and that figure rises to 1150 seven
litres with the rear seats folded down
and now to the cabin the dashboard is
trimmed in carbon fiber the five black
and red air vents blend in perfectly and
you don't even notice that the sport
seats colors are not in fact genuine
leather the special edition has a
seven-speed automatic performance
transmission the shift times can be
varied in the three modes Comfort Sport
and manual
i'm here at the 50 AMG really made an
effort with the sound design reckon
Sasha the exhaust features an
electronically controlled flap to
minimize annoying noise a hinderance oil
so does the super hot hatch have what it
takes
there are often on foot the thrills of
the a45 AMG do not come cheap sums up
Sasha almost 50 thousand euros but who'd
still want to drive a regular a class
after you've experienced at 265
kilowatts of this baby favre and Hut the
only real drawback is the cost after all
the a45 AMG is twice as expensive as the
smallest regular a class
american style sedans becoming
increasingly popular in europe today
we're checking out the lancia thema
which is in fact a second-generation
chrysler 300c
yia yia underneath your summer a few
years ago our test driver mattis was
driving around these parts in a Chrysler
300c wagon but feared has since bull
hump Chrysler and restructured the brand
a successor to the Chrysler 300c some
parts now also known as the Chrysler 300
is called the Lancia Thema in Europe
lancia tema Lancia hopes to win over new
customers with the Tema but its success
depends on the improvements made some
comfort features have been added for the
european version
was to get Matusz finds the car more
comfortable to drive in the Chrysler
300c the steering and gears of Flemmer
because they've been specially adapted
for the European market he also notes
that the brakes are more reliable than
they used to be loudly Farley avz does
for yoga let's take a look at the Thema
from the outside the bi-xenon headlights
come with a smart beam function so they
adjust from low to high beam
automatically the car has a wheelbase of
3.5 2 meters and 18-inch alloy wheels
come as standard the trunk holds 462
litres before folding down the rear
seats overall the car comes together
harmoniously and both the front and rear
eggs oooo Dan American vibe
inside the lancia thema comes across as
tidy and functional with the upholstery
providing a luxurious feel the model we
tested had a 3.6 liter v6 gas engine
with an output of 200 in 10 kilowatts it
accelerates from nought to 100
kilometres an hour in 7.9 seconds it's
not the most energy efficient vehicle
however eating up nine point four liters
of fuel per 100 kilometers its top speed
is 240 kph
just plays license plate has been
managed thinks the cost effectiveness of
the lancia thema is truly phenomenal for
a little over 50000 euros he can get a
model with all the trimmings including a
leather-coated dash heated seats
ventilated seating upfront or for
captive speed control line spot
detection I'm the sound system with an
8.4 inch touchscreen and it's everything
his heart could desire come on fiat saw
a touchscreen Alice fastest out spaghett
that's nice this most everything about
the theme it comes out top compared to
its predecessor except for one thing the
navigation system it has a large enough
display but sometimes it just doesn't
react and fails to display a map at
times location pin is 10 kilometres off
the mark you wouldn't recommend it to
those who are really reliant on sat navs
then have you got c1 system I'm good
reason is that is the super hope leads
the lancia thema comes with a range of
four engines to gasoline and to diesel
variant output between 140 hundred and
seventy-six and 210 kilowatts you also
have a choice between an eight speed or
five-speed automatic gearbox
as a BEM team up to is the Thema an
American or Italian car was matt is the
basic form is definitely American except
for a few Italian design elements he
also finds the interior more Italian
than American in the end he says it's a
car for individualists considering that
only a few hundred units were sold in
Germany over the last year and power and
that she took that phone [ __ ] off the
car is a look at however drives known as
comfortably competition theme is
medicago vents lancia thema it's
available in Germany from a starting
price of forty one thousand four hundred
euros though the model we tested costs
fifty thousand nine hundred introducing
BMWs 4 series coupe a technically this
would be a two-door three series with a
50 millimeter wheelbase and 43
millimeter rear however it's visibly
larger than the outgoing model and lower
22 gasoline engines and one diesel unit
will be available on its launch covering
a performance range of between 135 and
225 kilowatts in Germany the entry-level
model the BMW 420d kupe will hit the
market at 39,000 and 200 euros
factory specifications list 3.1 liters
of fuel per 100 kilometers for the new
Porsche Panamera S e-hybrid this is a
sports car with an electronic heart it's
plug-in hybrid means theoretically that
its range in a power mode is between 18
and 36 kilometers it has an output of
306 kilowatts with 590 newton meters of
torque on electric power alone it can
reach 135 kilometers per hour before the
diesel engine kicks in in Germany the
launch price is expected to be a hundred
and ten thousand four hundred and nine
euros
the owner promised us something exotic
and unconventional a car with a special
purpose that you won't otherwise see in
Europe this sports car perhaps too
capricious this one's pretty special
that hard exotic about this baby
this is a 1994 chevrolet caprice 9c1
originally serving the Los Angeles
Police Department its current owner
knows how to treat it right he happens
to be a police officer himself we take
off for a test drive his colleagues have
agreed to turn a blind eye today to
allow Andre to show what his Caprice is
capable of descriptor to initial or flag
of course there are particular
modifications required by law explains
Andre the police lights have to be
covered up and deactivated and the
sirens likewise have to be installed but
that meets like this or at photo shoots
they're up and running the main thing is
observing the regulations that are part
of the car's registration here my
country is guarding them bird this
Caprice is fitted with Chevrolet's 9c1
police package in this case a special
5.7 liter v8 engine with an automatic
box it's had no rust no accidents and
particularly important for a real police
cars history no previous civilian owners
but this Caprice owner it's a dream come
true
chef Andre always had his eye out on the
market and at some point he saw the
caprice in fell in love he wrote to the
seller and thank God he replied his head
the car was still available and he
offered him a good price it's a wasn't a
possible iodine and what a catch it was
for Andre the object of his desire was
taken care of well when still serving
and protecting it seems this model
survived any high-speed pursuits
unscathed the original light bar is in
top condition as other police codes and
logos the v8 doesn't need much prompting
to unleash the contents of its green
coolant hoses this is pure adrenaline
not water the engine can call up some
264 horsepower in order to catch the bad
guys the classic unity spotlights are
also still on board plastic plastered
interior isn't too welcoming and the
steering wheel is like in a huge
performance sedan aside from the radio
and the blazing lights and sirens the
car has no further extras the seti no
partition cage is still there it's dirt
resistant and can be cleaned
well my car now I'm saying it of any
sort the Americans aren't too good at
interiors reckons Andre there's loads of
elastic and in the case of these cars
low quality plastic you have to take
care not to break anything tibbetts look
uh personal body he's fortunate that
this interior is in relatively good
shape but otherwise it's a robust car
the engine sturdy from war toys under
the cameras or the woman exposure or
click bunny couple the Caprice 9c1 is
hardly a classic beauty the rounded body
and it the nickname beached whale
although it's predatory qualities are
more like those of a shark stepping on
the gas the car belies its weight of
almost two tons speedy and smooth
awesome this is why Andre plump for a9 c
1
cuz I'm Park it it's the overall package
the power and the size and everything
underneath this is a muscle car at a gas
guzzler it's fun to drive and great to
cruise around in a piece of America back
home with football from warszawie
cruising I merely cut some unfasten
Fenster Hall as a quazy Andre and his
trusty steed head out on another
adventure the Americans Chevy has lost
his beating v8 heart to a German police
officer